what's this one of these rolls that like
you had a like fun doing or was it
because of the seriousness like you're
playing someone you know maybe a little
PTSD maybe a little bit of a has some
you know questionable things you know
what I mean
I I thought of it as I mean you don't
want it like you don't want to take that
stuff for granted and you don't want to
like just play that stuff for fun
because that's all really serious things
and that's what you got it
incorporated into the character but on a
on a base level I thought the script was
really good fun the great like your
t-shirt that film is not considered a
comedy it's not a comedy but it is a
funny funny movie Goodfellas right and
it was a similar thing with this it was
like this is a really fun film as well
as being dark and having points to make
about misogyny in the way that the world
is wrong and racism and everything apart
from all that it's also a fun movie and
that's what drew me to and I thought
well we can really have fun with that
and then knowing that people involved
having fun with those people is like why
on earth would you not want to do that
the thing about this film is that it's
very ambitious for it's like 38 days
shooting schedule right somebody's
editor Iran I couldn't believe it was
that they shot it in 38 days idiots I
can't believe they did that like they
got it I'm stunned yeah but that also
adds to the production schedule you know
you need to make your shots you know you
have to have your a-game right on set so
talk a little bit did you ever feel that
and do you enjoy that environment it's
interesting you know I think it's a
little bit like a like traffic though
you know if you build an extra three
lanes onto a highway cars will fill that
highway like rush hour will still be
ramped so even if you're on a film that
has a 200 day shooting schedule every
day will be pretty full you don't I mean
they'll find stuff to fill it with it
never feels relaxed this wasn't relaxed
put it but it felt yeah I felt like we
were working all the time which is a
nice feeling you don't feel like you're
spending a lot of time waiting which is
good
completely before I run out of time with
you I'm definitely asking was the
highway analogy a bad no I use a good
two minutes at the highway analogy we
okay with that's right yeah I'm still
talking about it right check no I have I
have to ask you what what is it like now
like because you're part of the Star
Wars franchise what does it mean to you
to
part of this thing and the fact that you
know it's a huge part of so many
people's lives it's not the way I think
about us is it is the total honest truth
that being blase like it's I like being
part of good films I think the two films
and hopefully the three films because
I'm not seeing the third one I hope I
think there were two really really good
films I hope the next one to really go
on to I like being in good movies more
than I like being in franchises or
anything else so similarly to this I'm
just proud to have been part of
something good because oftentimes it
doesn't work out so when it does it
feels great
cool um I definitely want to know and I
know no spoilers of course but what was
it like reading that script for the
first time for episode 9 like is it sort
of like this is the last one with the
Skywalker's this is it it was cool it
was a page-turner and it was different
than what I had thought and it was great
it was great it was exciting and also
you feel part of this tiny club that
gets to read these things ahead of other
people and that feels great
I thought if I really did enjoy that and
I think it's going to be cool